we hear this all the time you know fail
fast fail often and I have an issue with
that because the word fail is just too
big it's like the word cancer right if
you have stage four liver cancer and if
you have a mild melanoma those are very
very different things the problem is
they're both called cancer well failure
is the same thing failure can be
catastrophic it also could be a mild
mild hiccup the word is too broad we
actually need a second word I actually
like the word falling failure I think we
should try and avoid I think failing is
a difficult and horrible thing but
Falling we should fall off and we should
scrape our knees and get back up so I do
believe in Falling which means Pusher
boundaries make mistakes try new things
you know be curious go outside your
comfort zone and if you fall get back up
and try again falling helps us build the
skills so that we don't have to fail